if the government is serious about its
net zero ambitions we're going to need
some details say analysts including this
former government advisor and given the
time scales we'll have to see them soon
in order to to believe this is likely to
have a huge ramp up in uh renewables in
wind power offshore and onshore wind and
solar you're gonna have to have a huge
ramp up in nuclear this is a massive
challenge
innovators the kind we work with the the
catapult and industry are up for it but
they're going to need clear direction
from government
his organization's latest report seen
exclusively by sky news finds under any
scenario the 10 gigawatts of offshore
wind power we currently have needs to
increase at least five times and
probably a lot more to meet net zero
and we'll probably need three times more
nuclear power than we have right now up
to 26 gigawatts but it also finds we'll
need huge amounts of zero carbon
hydrogen of which we currently have none
but it's closer than you might think in
this lab at itm power in sheffield water
and electricity is going into an
electrolyzer hydrogen and oxygen is
bubbling out
it's the r d behind the largest
electrolyzer factory in the world
its aim to make enough hydrogen to
replace increasingly pricey natural gas
everyone's committed to green energy i
think what we're really trying to
discuss is how we accelerate that
commitment and actually make it a closer
reality as opposed to being further
afield and i think the commitment is
which green
energy supplies
electrons and hydrogen not that it's not
that it's one or the other in terms of
fossil fuels it must be green renewable
energy
to drive the point home just down the
road is a forecourt where wind energy is
converted to hydrogen on site used to
fill hydrogen-powered cars
in theory hydrogen is the perfect
complement to an electricity grid
dominated by lots of wind power because
on those really windy days when you've
got an excess of electricity you can
make lots of hydrogen which you can then
store to fuel cars power industry or
make more electricity on those calm days
when you haven't got any wind power
the challenge is turning that theory
into practice
a major commitment to renewables will
ensure a future for hydrogen but clear
policies need to be in place to deliver
a low carbon electricity grid and we
don't have them yet
tom clark sky news sheffield